yeah welcome a new video playing mr.
Boris from the UK and let's play Queens
gambit mr. Boris I never played the sky
are you sure and it's not Boris Becker
most likely let's have a look oh it's
got a couple of five-minute games in
already but five minute specialists oh
ok zoom is laughs um I'll go for the
exchange variation it's not the most
dangerous son kind of exchange in this
sir and this line but I don't want a
very complicated game just try to keep
it simple a good response again this
early Quincy to as night to a six but he
didn't go for that yeah Bishop g5 Bishop
f5 now is actually a problem now Bishop
queen bee three sm is some a good answer
he needs to play what there should be
seven this this simply gives away the d5
pawn c8 is saying so
okay so now you just don't need to use
any to convert this it's very good of
course but it's just porn at the moment
admittedly it's a it's a big Center porn
but he's got a bishop here and so on so
um let's try to play decently here
technically okay just III Bishop e2 and
castles I guess need to complete
development okay so how to how to make
progress he can go Boop to f5 of course
and detect the Queen I can slow think
about a kind of minority check with
before b5 I'm I like that actually
shouldn't be a bad plan let's let's
prepare this
yeah this is some a bit of a shame how
to how to answer that now yeah okay I
don't want to repeat moose Queenie to is
a bit unnatural of course but h3 next
move will kick the bishop back now the
idea is 94 to c5 this was my intention
okay so let's win win win the tempo here
and then see about 95 I see one problem
is this Knight c3 move yeah on this is
got 93 and also before is hanging so
slightly am slightly tricky okay let's
go here cover b4 and c3 and PPR 95
you have a probably drop back all the
way to see aid
I don't mind my day 6 really be fiber
sir I can play be five anyway next move
yeah I think it's just a pawn more or
less I don't think he's got anything
special going yeah he's got this b6
response but I have night a forwards
which somehow clocks up is its pieces a
lot I mean be 69 a4s is still very
annoying c6 hangs and I don't see how it
keeps keeps his pawns
now this is the Cystic this is
interesting still okay but still have
soubise b6 NC 5 of saying so i can take
here and take c5 so where's the big the
big trick coming tonight to be 6 million
yeah the promise I mean he's not really
a threatening much not before maybe okay
come on let's take it I could have done
this much quicker of course and maybe I
should have done this much quicker there
were some alternatives that simply kept
kept an advantage without getting into
let's say the spin on the default just
down just a slow move would have been
really good as well but if I can take it
there's not not much reason why not to
I actually only seen I'd be 6 cm
blocking the pawn otherwise I just go be
six I keep I control all the squares ok
Knight c3 maybe he wants to play but
still I be 60 KD covered ok he covered
this but I've got 94 right I can go to
deform yeah come on let's go to deform
Queen g5i outside night 94
maybe you can go night f-for here the
Sun I didn't really look at hmm yeah
it's a bit tricky come on let's let's
retreat can always take take later let's
say on Queen g5 like and I can always
take Jack Jack
a key that's the bishop on g7 aha
idiotic didn't oh wow yeah this was
really unnecessary to get into this
trouble came coverage three on top imma
be porn is some deciding
time warning check check Wow Jeff Jeff
Jeff Jeff black wow wow this was lucky
timewise I'm 174 hundredths of a second
came in the position of course i SAT ii
was was was very much winning but I
really allowed lots of things I should
just take here of course I I thought of
yeah i saw this but I didn't really
realize he can take of course you should
be forced even stronger again this now
of course I just got it just got the big
big attack and yeah computer says it's
winning ass black ah yeah of course
after after this is was just a big mess
I could have one on time probably by
just moving quickly but I still wanted
to try to try to defend this yeah it's
got his God for us mates here this is a
force mate yeah I cannot I cannot
prevent the force made Queen have three
years made into but is on one second so
yeah Queen her three again made into yam
okay this is just the problem of non
increment blitz I mean
the Sun would have won four black easily
here with just a little bit more time I
of course I just need to I just need to
take em and then there's not not much
happening can can have a look at here
probably needs to go here and then
something like this and it's a it's how
many poles to poles and the the big
point is cell is a huge asset of course
yeah I didn't see this this coming in
the deformed you could just take before
yeah thanks for watching this a very
very very close game at the end time was